الى التطورات على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره
باطلاق صاروخين من جنوب لبنان باتجاه موقع
اسرائيلي في اصبع الجليل وقال المتحدث
باسم بلديه كريات شموه ان اربعه صواريخ
سقطت في مناطق مفتوحه بالبلده دون تسجيل
اصابات او اضرار من جهتها افاد مراسل
الجزيره ان قصفا مدفعيا اسرائيليا استهدف
اطراف بلده الخيام جنوب بلبنان وكان حزب
الله اعلن امس عن تنفيذ اربع عمليات ضد
مواقع اسرائيليه قباله الحدود الجنوبيه
للبنان ينضم الينا من مرجع يون جنوب لبنان
مراس الجزيره ايهاب العقده معك حول
التطورات والوضع على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه يبدو ان حزب الله مستمر في
معركه الاسناد لقطار غزه حتى تحقيق وقف
اطلاق النار هذا الامر بدا يظهر من خلال
العمليات المستمره من قبل حزب الله والتي
اتسمت بنوعيتها خلال الاسبوع الماضي حزب
الله شن اربع هجمات يوم امس هذا اليوم
اطلق صاروخين باتجاه احد المواقع في اصبع
الجليل لكن لم يتبنى حتى اللحظه حزب الله
هذه العمليه وهي جزء من سلسله العمليات
التي كان شنها في هذه المنطقه تحديدا
عند تخوم قريات شموه وغيرها من البلدات ال
او المستوطنات المحاذيه لها حزب الله كان
بالامس ركز الهجمات على منطقه تلال كفر
شوبه ومزارع شبعه التي شن باتجاهها ثلاث
هجمات قال انه حقق اصابات في في المواقع
التي استهدفها بالصواريخ الموجهه وبث صورا
تظهر استخدام
صواريخ ذكيه موجهه من قبل حزب الله باتجاه
هذه المواقع وحقق اصابات وفقا للصور التي
بثها الجانب الاسرائيلي كان ايضا استخدم
الطائرات الحربيه وهو ما داب عليه منذ
اكثر من اربعه اسابيع في الرد على عمليات
حزب الله شن غاره على محيط بلده كفرشوبا
الليله الماضيه كما شنت الطائرات هجوما
على منط على بلده الجبين كل هذه المناطق
ايضا كانت تستهدف باستمرار من جانب
اسرائيل بالغارات وبقص المدفعي هذا اليوم
ايضا الجانب الاسرائيلي قصف محيط بلده
الخيام بالاضافه الى بعض القذائف التي
اطلقها باتجاه محيط بلده الناقوره بلده
الخيام سقط فيها قذيفتان دخان تان بين
المنازل المدنيه ربما في ذلك مؤشر الى
محاوله ارهاب من تبقى من المدنيين داخل
هذه البلده التي يقصف طرفها الجنوبي
واطرافها الشرقيه والغربيه باستمرار من
جانب المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
التي تتمركز في المستوطنات القريبه من
لبنان الطائرات الحربيه وكذلك المسيرات
تواصل تحليقها في جنوب لبنان في محاوله
لمسح الوضع الميداني هنا وتحركات مقاتلي
حزب الله في هذه المنطقه في هذا الجو
العاصف والما طر